only a year and a half after being
formed the Dutch coalition government
has collapsed
it's no secret that the Coalition
Partners have very different views on
migration policy and today unfortunately
we have to conclude that those
differences are irreconcilable that's
why I will immediately offer the
resignation of the entire cabinet to the
king in writing
the Prime Minister tried to force
through to cap the number of refugees
but his Junior Coalition Partners
refused
it's a difficult moment we've held
intensive talks about all sorts of
measures to stop the influx of Asylum
Seekers this has not been easy we also
have to make room for those who do have
the right to a safe haven in the
Netherlands
the Netherlands is expecting around 70
000 Asylum applicants this year that's
almost double last year's number
and that's increased pressure on the
government from far-right parties like
the party for Freedom or pvv led by hurt
builders
foreign
has been the country's longest serving
leader but his staunch stance on
migration has ended his fourth term in
government and possibly his last Imran
Allah Al Jazeera